别人能挣150万的，
公公婆婆在我面前批评我两句，
这叫贬低吗？
这不叫贬低，
这是客观的，
我确实没有人家有本事，
我要是有这个本事的话，
我是不是也能挣150万了，
我没有人家有本事，
所以人家说这句话叫客观的评价，
这不叫贬低。
我跟我老公结婚有15年了，
我的话是40岁个月收入的话有5800，
父母的话是他是工资有6800，
我妹妹的话他也是结了婚的，
然后老公家有点钱，
我的性格的话是比较外向的，
摆过地摊，
做过我加盟的品牌店呀，
全是在家待了14年的孩子嘛。
再说一下我老公的情况，
他就是跟我一样，
40岁，
他没有工作，
平常就是炒股，
一直说他赚了，
我也不知道，
他也没给我看，
而且他是啃老的，
就是全靠他父母养着，
他用我们的房子贷款700多个左右吧，
主要是用于投资的，
他哥哥的话做建材生意的，
然后现在生意不怎么好，
其实现在也是你工作，
他父母的话是生意人，
做那个餐饮的，
一年的话有550个左右吧，
因为我查了很多资料嘛，
查过那个豆包，
还有短视频这些，
我分析我老公90%多的属于NP地，
我觉得他以前对孩子特别狠，
我自己也有意那个啥了，
他属于那种讨好父母型的，
就特别讨好父母，
因为他父母能挣钱嘛，
因为我工作是最近一两年才工作的，
他就比较嫌弃我跟我孩子就。
做什么，
他就是打压我们了，
见不得我稍微休息一下啊，
他父母的话脾气也不是很好，
对于我的话，
我觉得还行，
因为我们每年回去一次嘛，
他妈妈呢，
稍微好一点，
因为他妈妈有时候和我老公就是吵架，
稍微会负责过一点，
那关键时刻的话，
他肯定还是会或者他儿子的，
我再说一下我们的那个共同财产，
儿子15岁，
你儿子话8岁，
我们在新一线城是有三套房，
大概总价值在300万左右吧，
有一套150万的，
是在婚前他个人买的，
有两套呢，
是婚后买的，
我们在老家有一套，
可能100左右，
现在有贷款3000左右，
漂亮国的话也有一套，
可能只700多吧，
那个是属于他个人名义买的，
他有一辆那个2011年买的20万的车，
我有一辆18年30万的车子，
他给我卖，
负债的话，
老家的月供3000嘛，
金一县的三套房是没有贷款，
他是抵押了的，
总共有700多个，
乱投资了，
差不多现在就欠700多个，
漂亮国内那个房是以房养房的，
我现在这种情况的话，
适不适合他分开，
因为我现在收入也不多嘛，
也比较少，
爸妈那边的退休金加起来也就6000块钱，
你这边的月收入也就5000块钱，
这些资产大概率上都是他父母的资产投资到你们身上的，
因为他也不挣钱，
你也不挣钱，
这些资产都是爷爷奶奶的资产，
尤其奶奶对你还不错。
就不是啊，
对，
他爷爷奶奶基本上平常每年回家干活吧，
我不是很能干活，
但是我会尽力去干嘛，
每一次回去我就尽力去干，
也不会说我，
因为他还有嫂子子，
嫂子特别能干，
他们也不会，
你说来比较啊啥的，
然后他们家就属于那种典型的打压式的，
很多负能量的那子，
比如说她嫂子，
我以前跟他在一起啊，
经常说老公长得丑，
就是说儿子成绩不好，
要不就是我同事对块吧，
后来我就没跟他接触了，
我自己的感觉就是他们一家负能量挺多的，
我是这么看这个问题的，
离了之后，
你未必能分到心目中想象的这一半的财产，
因为所有的钱都是爷爷奶奶挣来的嘛，
你们两口子相当于是没挣钱，
因为你一个月挣5000块钱，
一家人的开销，
孩子两个，
你老公炒股也没挣到什么钱，
所以这些钱都是爷爷奶奶的，
真的要分的时候，
未必，
咱未必能分到钱，
其次呢，
又没有跟爷爷奶奶住在一起，
爷爷奶奶现在还做生意呢，
一年也见不到多少面。
假设我是一个月挣5000块钱，
我说假设啊，
我拉扯两个孩子，
这种情况下，
我把爷爷奶奶就得当金主，
她贬低我应该的呀，
这不叫贬低，
这叫客观。
姐妹们啊，
咱们客观一点，
一年能挣150万的公公婆婆在我面前批评我两句，
这叫贬低吗？
这不叫贬低，
这是客观的，
我确实没有人家有本事，
我要是有这个本事的话，
我是不是也能挣150万了，
我没有人家有本事，
所以人家说这句话叫客观的评价，
这不叫贬低，
这个我知道，
因为我。
他父母是没有什么看法，
他父母对我挺好的，
我唯一为啥想到这年轻，
因为我老公真经有七八年了吧，
我每做一件事情爱打压，
我打压孩子，
你跟你老公现在也分居了，
对不对对，
也不是说天天在一口锅里吃饭，
天天要看他的脸色，
你现在应该什么呢？
我什么心态呢？
有一种心态特别绝，
其实我合作伙伴嘛，
不是合作伙伴这个概念是把你老公当我一样，
反正跟我是分居的，
我俩都不住一块儿，
我现在每个月又有钱又有房，
我等着爷爷奶奶死了我老公了，
只要我活的比我老公长什么都是我和我孩子的，
他们在给我打工，
哎，
我之前也是这么想的，
分居的话是刚刚分开，
那是因为我儿子是初三了嘛，
要中考，
对呀，
我就一心把孩子照顾好，
把孩子的心理照顾好，
把孩子的学习照顾好，
他们都在给我打工，
都在给我的儿子打工，
不用他们来给我情绪价值吗？
我用他们来夸我吗？
我不用，
我还得给他们提供情绪价值。
爷爷，
你一定要保重身体啊，
奶奶，
你一定要多吃点营养品啊，
爷爷奶奶加油干啊，
爷爷奶奶一年挣150万啊，
10年是1500万啊，
你得加油干，
我用得着他们来夸我吗？
用得着他们来肯定我吗？
来给我情绪价值吗？
用不着一点，
只要我活得足够长，
这些人都在给我打工，
照着让他们得活100岁去，
我是懂的，
这么长时间嘛，
你。
我肯定是考虑过这个的，
我现在觉得我好像实在是忍不了了，
因为孩子也大了，
就是因为我老公确实90%都是MPD，
那现在不是分居了嘛，
刚刚分开，
但是半年以后会回来，
将来孩子如果说要上什么国外的学校，
你是不是可以去陪读去了，
就他不会，
他不可能让孩子去国外读书的啊，
不去国外读书，
孩子有没有可能上那种比较好一点的高中，
你得在旁边租个房子陪着孩子，
他不会让我的，
因为孩子现在学习上所有的东西他都不让我管，
不让我参与，
比如说管了，
因为我是在管我玩儿嘛，
晚上我想去接儿子，
他都不让我去接，
有时候我都是悄悄自己去接，
很多事情他不让，
他都想控制，
以前孩子的生活上的一些东西，
他就会指挥我给孩子做什么做什么，
但是我一做他就觉得不好，
不让，
如果说得生活在一起的话，
可能就解不了这个扣，
要是有办法不生活在一起的话，
或许能解这个扣，
这不刚刚就是开学嘛，
他跟儿子搬出去了，
我就很开心，
又想跟你咨询这个问题嘛，
但是他4个月了以后还是会回来，
我就很焦虑，
因为他在家里，
他是随时逼着脸的，
但凡看到我开心，
不许发脾气的，
不想我开心，
这孩子也跟我开开心心的玩个啥呀，
他是会那种很想发脾气的感觉，
你想问我的问题是什么呢？
这两年我才想到，
就是分不分开，
因为我这两年我工作了嘛，
之前没有工作，
我自己也拎得清我是什么情况，
那个时候我就没。
掌握，
我就想孩子大一点，
如果不适合的话，
什么时候可以分，
比如说我有多少存款嘛，
我现在在一步一步努力嘛，
第二个就是刚才你说了，
就是分财产，
可能分不到多少是吧，
因为钱坦率的说都不是你两口子挣的钱嘛，
都是爷爷奶奶出的钱，
他肯定有证据嘛，
你要说想分多少的话，
这个说不好，
分是能分到一部分，
但你能分到那么多吗？
那可未必，
我很知知足的，
我不是说要分很多，
有一套房子住，
或者一套或者两套给我，
其他我都不要，
都可以，
或者是我能分到一套房子，
给我几十或者百八万的我都可以，
我这个人是能屈能伸的，
哪怕是小弟保洁都行，
我只要孩子跟我这里开开心心的，
我都可以到什么时候比较适合分，
我说这话有点歹毒了，
爷爷奶奶去世了适合分，
因为爷爷奶奶去世了之后还有遗产继承，
那个时候就是法律上你能分了，
去世了他也不会讲究什么债权的问题，
讲究我给你花了多少钱，
我给你买房出了多少钱，
也不讲这个问题了。
嗯，
好的，
要不就是我自己有能力赚到很多钱是吗？
对呀，
要不就是你自己有能力赚到钱，
能维持这个体面的生活。
比如像我这种情况，
我两个孩子现在这个年纪的话，
我一个月收入多少？
在一线城市你觉得比较宽松呢？
一个人带俩孩子在一线城市怎么也得30万打底过的，
都是属于那种不太敢打车，
不太给孩子报夏令营啊，
报什么班啊，
真的啊，
一线城市消费就是这么可怕，
我跟你讲我的，
因为我们现在境确实。
我不想，
嗯，
好，
谢谢谢谢，
嗯，
拜拜啊，
因为现在孩子真的是花钱跟流水似的，
如果说在一线城市带着俩孩子，
30万打底是什么意思？
就是你30万你才能维持一个正常的运转，
正常的他上学放学买校服，
买各种各样的孩子需要的学习用品，
参考书，
什么学习机，
孩子又要跟着老师，
又要去社会实验，
又要参加什么活动，
参加什么这夏令营那学习营，
真的30万是打底，
够你吃，
够你喝，
够你娘仨过一个正常人的日子，
一线城市能养两个孩子比较有勇气啊，
记得点赞关注哦。